the Trump DeSantis Feud has exploded as
Donald Trump spent the entire weekend
posting to truth social truth essential
attacks on Ron DeSantis including going
full Rhino Trump giving Ron DeSantis the
full Rhino treatment remember that Rhino
means Republican in name only it's a
pejorative attached to Republicans that
someone feels aren't really Republican
so let's take a look at Trump's posts he
is not holding back despite claiming he
doesn't even think about Ron DeSantis he
spent the entire weekend posting about
him Trump first posting quote in writer
Selena Zito's fake news puff piece about
DeSantis which supposedly appeared in
the dying New York Post which is way
down in readership just like Fox News is
way down in ratings why doesn't she
mention that he wants to cut Social
Security and Medicare loves losers like
Jeb Bush Paul Ryan and Karl Rove
and it getting clobbered in the polls by
me DeSantis is a rhino who is trying to
hide his past I don't read the New York
Post anymore it has become fake news
just like Fox and The Wall Street
Journal anyone who doesn't suck up to
Trump and pray at the altar of the uh
great failed former president is now a
rhino and is fake news and is bad
but understand that this is a dramatic
escalation Trump last week said I don't
even think about Ron DeSantis and then
he spent the entire weekend trothing
about Ron DeSantis Trump continuing
Trump content and by the way isn't Trump
really the Rhino and what I mean by that
is Trump never represented Republican
values Trump wasn't even really a
republican that we knew of for the vast
majority of his life until he started
getting traction by criticizing Barack
Obama
um if there's any real Rhino it's
actually Trump but let's put that aside
for a second Trump continuing to post
quote Ron de sanctimonious wants to cut
your Social Security and Medicare closed
up Florida and its beaches loves rhinos
Paul Ryan Jeb Bush and Karl Rove
disasters all is backed by globalists
club for no growth Lincoln pervert
project and uninspired Coke
and it only gets worse from there he is
a rhino in Disguise whose poll numbers
are dropping Like a Rock Good Luck run
you know for a guy who says I don't
think about Ron DeSantis he will not
stop posting about Ron DeSantis and
seems completely consumed by Ron
DeSantis and that's how you know Trump
is lying when he says I don't ever think
about this thing and anybody who says I
do is wrong and bad and evil and lying
it's a signal that that's exactly what
he's spending his time thinking about
and it's clear that he is and then
another one this morning Trump just out
of control truth essential quote support
for DeSantis cools in latest GOP poll
Washington Times of course it cools he
wants to cut Social Security and
Medicare loves throw them off the cliff
Paul Ryan who is destroying Fox News In
The Wall Street Journal piglet Carl Rove
and quote Jeb also Ron de sanctimonious
is for globalist club for no growth and
open borders Charles Koch we want
America First not America last that's
the ranting of a Madman there's no
denying it there's no way around it but
I said I don't know if all of these guys
and gals really have what it takes to
face Trump in a national campaign in
which Trump ignores all rules of decorum
the very same ignoring of all the rules
of decorum that made the us a joke
internationally When Donald Trump was
President are the rules of decorum that
generate media attention and that get
those folks who aren't that close
followers of politics but they like a
good fight and an interesting combative
personality it brings them out of the
woodwork and that's why Trump won in
2016. it was missing from 2020. that
part of why Trump lost 2020 aside from
failing on covid uh is that he didn't
have the environment that he had in 2016
to do this sort of stuff this really is
Trump in his element that's the crazy
thing and so I know not everybody in the
audience agrees with me on this
I think unless someone can match Trump
on this sort of stuff
um he has a very good shot at running
away with the 2024 nomination let me
know what you think leave a comment
leave a comment let me know what you
think and uh look forward to hearing
from you did you know that every year 30
million trees are cut down to meet the
demand of toilet paper in the United
States alone here's something really
simple you can do to fight climate
change a little bit in your home our
sponsor real paper makes toilet paper
100 from bamboo stocks which keep
growing forever no trees are cut down
it's shipped right to your door in
plastic free packaging it's fluffy it's
soft like regular toilet paper you're
not making any quality sacrifice and for
every box you buy real paper donates to
reforestation efforts Across America
through their partnership with one tree
planted so instead of the toilet paper
you're currently buying which cuts down
trees and wastes plastic use real paper
actively helping the planet you can set
up a recurring subscription so you're
always stocked or do a one-time purchase
the average American uses 50 pounds of
toilet paper or more every year make the
easy switch switch to real paper you'll
get thirty percent off your first order
plus free shipping go to realpaper.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below